I just think you have to put out content
speed and volume and the problem is most
people struggle with both and that's why
most people aren't successful the reason
you're not breaking out is two of the
pillars besides quality are speed and
volume like that's that's the formula
the formula is speed quantity and
quality that's it and the third one you
can't control like not everybody's going
to be charismatic not everybody's gonna
be funny not everybody's gonna be
attractive but the other two you can if
you break it so many people are
struggling without putting out
compelling content or they're
half-assing it because they're
overthinking their content and then that
means they're slow when you overthink
you slow down when you're slow somebody
passes you